[Music]
the Houston Texans are helping their
city in the wake of hurricane Harvey a
fundraising campaign launched by
defensive end JJ Watt has already
collected more than 18 and a half
million dollars yesterday the football
players handed out water and critical
supplies to storm dictums Michelle
Miller is in Houston with more of the
story Michelle good morning good morning
hurricane Harvey did not discriminate
members of the texans football team also
flooded but JJ Watt and crew knew they
had the means to push through now they
want to make sure the rest of their city
does with boxes of supplies water even
hugs JJ Watt and teammates are helping
to get the people of Texas back on their
feet on Sunday 10:00 semi trucks arrived
from Watson's home state of Wisconsin
filled to the brim with donated items
these are all volunteers so we haven't
even spent a single cent yet not a
single cent of the millions of dollars
he's fund raised wad says with a sum
this large he wants to make sure it's
managed correctly I'm going to take my
time make sure that I work with local
organizations that we do it right here
in the city so that money goes straight
to the people here of Houston who needed
the most so that we can help rebuild
them and that's where it went we watched
as the players handed out the donations
throughout the city at Christian
Tabernacle Church hundreds of cars
streamed in with people looking for
everything from water to bleach to cat
food and buckets for cleaning the
football players made sure they had what
they needed and helped out volunteers
that have been working in the heat for
hours it's not right for other people to
suffer Jordan Sturm era is one of those
volunteers a die-hard Texan fan he made
sure that while he worked hard he also
snapped some pictures he calls these
guys his heroes and today he got to see
them in action it's the best
they're coming out to do the right thing
the players also brought with them
moments of joy
we love the Texan for those who had
experienced a week of heartbreak I don't
know I'm gonna go Laura Hernandez says
mold has taken over her home but donning
JJ's number and getting signatures she
like many other volunteers still had a
smile on her face it excites me that
they're helping so much here and we can
give a hand to people that are in need
it's humbling to be able to see the way
the city's coming together going through
a hard time Texan safety Curtis Drummond
says it's volunteers like this that
keeps Houston strong just keep on
fighting I just stay together keep
playing and we'll bounce back their
original goal 10 million dollars guess
what they've raised 20 and that's with
lots and lots of small donations they've
had a few big ones Ellen DeGeneres just
pledged a million dollars of her own
Jeff Michelle Miller thank you very much
and the tech euston texans open at home
NFL season starts this week it'll be a
nice guys way for the city Astros on
Saturday yeah it's nice to see sports
helping at least provide a little
distraction JJ what everybody else yeah